e
[Müzik]
herkese merhaba
Asi Z Bugün bir mucizenin hikayesini
paylaşmak istiyorum bir mucize dünyaya
geldi ve dünyada işte
de ekranda görmüş olduğunuz
Derici kızımızı Elif nadir görülen
freecell koni sendromu ile dünyaya geldi
ama bu hikayenin farklı bir boyutu var
bu gebeliğin 18 haftası
bütün doktor kontrolü cinsiyetini
öğrenmek için doktora gidiyoruz ve
ultrasonda
bu dudak yarığı tespit ediyor ya hafta
sonra gidiyoruz damak yarığı tespit
ediliyor sonrasında Kulakların
gelişmediği ortaya çıkıyor
Ve bir ailenin hayatında
karşılaşabileceği en zor sorulardan biri
böyle devam mı tamam mı
Biz de normal yaşantınıza devam
ediyorduk toplum tarafından belirlenmiş
hedefler doğrultusunda koşuyorduk Özel
sektörde yol alıyorduk ama hayat bazen
öyle
bir acılar getiriyor ki karşınıza
çok farklı boyuta geçiyorsunuz
kontrol aramızdan vazgeçecek tik Elif
dünyaya gelmeliydi gelmemeliydi
çevremiz tarafından çokça aksi yönünde
görüş bildirildi
ileride mutlu olamaz
yaşıtlarıyla
konuşamaz
birçok kişi onunla alay eder ve
ama biz o sırada felsefi sorgulamaları
geldik tabii biyolojik açıdan baktık var
olursa az açıdan baktık dedik bir
insanın yaşamak Hı hı Kime göre neye
göre Mutluluğu sadece fiziksel olarak
tam ve bütün bireyler mi hak ediyor
ya da bir canlının Anne karnım için ya
da dışında olmasının bir farkı var mı
Hepsini bu zorlu süreçte de düşündük ve
bir karar almamız gerekiyordu
O karar verdik yolumuza devam ettik Hala
heyecanlanıyorum ilk günkü gibi Çünkü
çok zor süreçler yaşadık biz o dönemde
Ala da Yaşıyoruz bir seçim yaptık ve
geri kalan her şey BİM değil artık yola
baş koyacaktık karşılaşacak larımız
neydi onları da bilmiyorduk
şunu uzun zorlu bir yolculuk bizi
bekliyor dua
bu dünyaya geldi
çenenin geride olmasından dolayı kalıyor
ekranda gördüğünüz o takıldı konuyla
ilgili hiçbir şey bilmiyoruz treacher
Collins nedir yüz anomalisi nedir
Farklı sorunlar nedir bunların hiçbirini
bilmiyorduk Araştırdık o süreçte herkesi
Araştırdık fakat maalesef sağlıklı bir
bilgiye ulaşamadık ve karar verdik ne
olursa olsun Bu işin peşini gidecektik
araştırdım okuduğum ettim aileleri
bulmaya çalıştım iğne ile kazıya kazıya
yavaş yavaş olayları ulaştık ve ziyaret
etmeye başladık Elif hikaye yoğun
bakımda kaldı Sonrasında da evde de
solunum cihazıyla yaşamaya devam etti
aileleri ziyaret ettik Yani dır triconex
buz ne sorunlar yaşıyorsunuz
karşılaştığınız zorluklar nedir bize
anlatır mısınız dediler
Dedim dediler ki Ben çocuğumu ve
Arkadaşları alay etmesin diye parka dahi
çıkaramıyorum metrobüse biniyorum
arkadaşları insanlar sizin görüntünüz
den rahatsız Lütfen bu metrobüse
binmeyin okullara Bu çocukların dış
görünüşü nedeniyle alınmadık larına
şahit olduk hala öyle halâs benzer
sorunları toplumda görüyoruz
Zorlu bu insanların hayatlarından u
sandıkları bir süreçti ve ben onu olan
bir karar verdim Ben ne olursa olsun bu
işin peşine düşecektim ne olursa olsun
Bu çocukların yüzünün gülmesi için
mücadele edecektim geri kalan her şeyi
bıraktım
ailelerle iletişim kurduk onların
dertleriyle bile ilgilendik paylaştık
sonrasında yüzüne Mutlu yıllar Yeni
kurduk yüzüme mutluyum Derneği Ülkemizde
ilk ve tek Dernek kendi alanında
doğumsal sendromlar ın yanı sıra tümör
iz yanıt da çeşitli sebeplerle yüzünde
farklılık olan herkese bizi tabi
ediyoruz
ne mi yaptık bu aileleri bir araya
getirdik atölye çalışmaları yaptık Bugün
ellerine en büyük sorunu içe kapanma
izolasyon
dua onlara destek olmaya çalıştık
rehberler oluşturdu kılavuzlar
oluşturduk internet sitemizde paylaştık
Elimizden gelen ne varsa yaptık ve bunu
tamamen Biz kendi gönüllü Kafamızda
gerçekleştirdik
Ama şu anlar Unutulmaz the
benzer süreçleri yaşayan bireyler ilk
defa bir araya geliyordu oldu çoğu ya
Mahallede birbirini tanımıyor
ve aynı dertleri paylaşıyorlar ama
birbirinden farklı var ve o an gerçekten
unutulmazdır bu aralar ilk defa
birbirini gördü kendi yaşadıklarını
birbirleriyle paylaşmaya başladılar ve o
an benim için var yani şeyler vardır
Yani Artık ölsem de gam yemem O durumu
olmaya başlamıştı
bu okullara gidiyoruz farkındalık
sunumları yapıyoruz akran zorbalığı
sunumlarına başladık bunu tamamen kendi
imkanlarımızla okul okul geziyoruz
arkadaşlarımızı
yetiştiriyoruz gönüllerimiz var Hep
beraber okul okul gezip bu farkındalığı
artırmaya çalışıyoruz yüz bölgesinde
görülür ne farklı olursa olsun her
insanın Adil eşit bir yaklaşım
hakettiğini savunuyoruz biz
bu sonumuda Ben dün gece hazırladım
biraz spontane olsun istedim
içindekileri daha rahat paylaşırım diye
biraz o günler geldi aklıma o yüzden
duygulandım
bu
derneğimizi kurduk
ve bir yola çıktık biz bugünlere destek
olmak istiyoruz biz bu bireylerin
yaşamlarında Farkındalık yaratmak
istiyoruz biz bu bireylerin toplumla iç
içe olmasını istiyoruz bu bir soru devam
ettirirken geniş tuttuk vizyonumuz da
dedi ki biz uluslararası anlamda da
güzel işler yapalım hemen gittik
yurtdışı bağlantılarınızı kurduk Face
Quest International bizim gibi
derneklerin bir arada çalışmasını
hedefleyen ortak ya oraya ve olduk 33
ülkeden iPhone ip
işitme engelliler
gençler için kurulan bir dernek ve
eurordis Avrupa Nadir hastalıklara
gittik buralarda yüze çiftliğini
anlattık
İngiltere'ye gitti fon aldık İspanya'ya
Ali ziyaretleri yaptık Fransa'ya gittik
ha Romanya'ya gittik İsviçre'ye gittik
hep yok artık yüz eşitliğini anlattık
Hatta euror istedim Avrupa Nadir
hastalıklar anı yüz eşitliğini Biz
temsil etmeye başladık Ve bir baktık
gibi süre sonra biz yurt dışında basında
yer almaya başlıyoruz bize örnek kuruluş
olarak göstermeye başlıyorlar başladılar
bu bizim için çok gurur verici Bu
durumda
yüzüme mutluyum haftası yaptık kelebek
çizdik yüzümüze çocuklarımıza
bu ve sokakta yüzünde kelebekli
insanların gezmeleri istedik sosyal
medya etkinliklerinde paylaştık ve
müthiş be empati sağlandı
çocuklar
okullarında aktiviteler yaptık çocuklar
o güne kadar imal edilen arka planı
atılan çocuklar
ilk defa Okulda da krallar kraliçeler
gibi karşılanmaya başladılar
baronların hayatında Bir dönüm noktası
yarattık ve bu süreci anlattığım
mucizenin adı Elif isimli de
kitabına Kalem aldım bu süreçte de
bunların hepsi de yaşandı bitti çok kısa
sürede ve hayat devam ediyor Biz yüz
eşitliği istiyoruz yüz eşitliğini şu an
biz Birleşmiş Milletler gündeme dair
taşımaya çalışıyoruz nedir yüz eşitliği
insanın yüz görünümü nasıl olursa olsun
Adil ve eşit yaklaşıma hak ettiği bir
bilinç bu topluma bakıyoruz geçmişten
sözlü kültür yazılı kültür şu anda
görsel kültür Sen yakışıklı olmalısın
Sen güzel olmalısın ki bazı işleri
almalısın
yetenekli olmalısın ama dış görünüş Daha
önce geliyor biz bu kalıplara gitmeye
çalışıyoruz biz bu ezberleri bozmaya
çalışıyoruz bu alanda mücadele veren tek
derdiniz işimiz çok zor yerleri annene
karşı yarışıyoruz savaşıyoruz dayatılmış
ideal dış görünüş kalıplarını Biz
parçalamaya çalışıyoruz ve bunu yapan
tek Sivil Toplum Kuruluşu yüz arkamızda
hiçbir destek yok neler yapılmalı
okullarda müfredat Lara bu eğitim
sorunları konulmalı
işyerlerinde görünür farklılıkları olan
bireylere daha acil yaklaşım için
kılavuzlar oluşturmalı Hayatın her
alanında Biz yer almalıyız
ne anlatacak çok şey var
tabii zorluğu uzun bir yoldan Özel
sektörde çalışıyorum aynı zamanda
da işte günümüzde bir yol çıktı Elif'i
seçtik Elif'e devam ettik sonrasında
yüzlerce kişiye dokunduk ailelere
dokunduk dünya çapında ses getiren işler
yaptık takdir edildik
bu süreçte bende de çok farklılıklar
Oldu
oldu ben bu zamana kadar
bir hep yalnız adamı oynuyordu
konumuz temamız maskeye
dünya benim arkamda aydı ben
görememiştim bu süreçte Çokça da Hatalar
yaptım Bu Davaya adarken kendimi eşim
imal ettim arkadaşlarımı imal ettim
ailemi imal ettim Bir daha aradım mutlu
muyum mutluyum çünkü biz o zaman bulmuş
durumdayım ama şu an burada onlardan
herkesin huzurunda özür diliyorum bana
bu süreçte bu yaşıma kadar gelen herkese
emekleri için de ben çok teşekkür
ediyorum
ve şunu söylemek istiyorum Şunu söylemek
istiyorum
Eğer
bu süreçte şunu anladım Kendimi de daha
iyi tanımaya başladım ben bu dünyada Ne
para istiyorum ne bu istiyorum Ne makamı
istiyorum
birine dokunmak birini sevgiyle
paylaşmak Bir de topluma kazandırmak
kadar haz veren gurur veren başka bir
duygu da yok
Ben bu dünyada O çocukların Emre abisi
olarak geçip gitmek istiyorum Teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]